in a world
hi there welcome to the wall look at
this as a chance for a brand new life
what the where many are looking for
a way out
one hero thanks for coming hulk you're
the only one qualified enough to help
he's looking for a way in you saved so
many
but not everyone i gotta help them with
this investigation but the nightmares
a way to discover the truth i'll make
sure everyone here is safe
a way to find redemption these kind of
things don't happen in here anymore
we have a theory big old cricket a way
into the mind
you think a cricket did this of a killer
we have a serial killer on our hands
but in the world even small secrets
what you've done goes against everything
we fought for have
big consequences and this killer secret
story you know it's a lie can send the
whole world
tumbling down